listen boys your mother and i never
really prepared you for this
but you were going for it it's the one
division
series finale folks you know the drill
yep
this is et canada's nerd
carlos bustamante here wanda's climactic
battle with agatha harkness is like last
episode's ghosts of christmas past
psychological deep dive
a lesson for wanda in who she is and
what her true potential could be
for better or worse among the wizard of
oz references magic head trips and
flying super saiyan energy blasts
wanda and agatha play out a version of
their comic book relationship
student and teacher through a conflict
with agatha wanda learns to come to
terms with her troubled past
let go of her iron grip on her messy
present and charge
into an uncertain future she also learns
how to make this headpiece work
i admit i i was skeptical but you know
what
she's owning it but i'm not the true
vision
only a conditional vision meanwhile
vision continues to be the model of a
sophisticated modern superhero
after a super-powered bust-up he reasons
with his evil doppelganger using logic
and philosophy even the evil vision
can't resist a little
self-analysis the two of them talk it
out and literally unify
their vision with his memories and
humanity restored
white vision does what a true hero would
do and
lies away i'm gonna trust there's a good
reason for that but right now
it's a little sus man you're ralph
boner boner
speaking of which we gotta talk about
this a few weeks back evan peters
showing up as pietro set the internet on
fire with theories about
x-men and multiverses and spawned a
million memes of nerds like me
putting their scholarly knowledge of
fictional worlds to use forecasting what
would happen after what was surely the
moment
that was the turning point or darius a
nexus of marvel realities
finally beginning to align instead we
got ralph boner and his magical pooka
beads
now i like some good wordplay as much as
the next guy but this feels like a
letdown
did we just read way too much into all
those easter eggs get too drawn in by
those knowing winks and
comic lore pinning our hopes on
something that was never gonna happen
did we just get friend zoned by ralph
there's always the possibility that we
don't know the full story yet
but for now i'm not holding out any hope
at least we got to see even more of
monica's powers that she got rid of his
ridiculous necklace monica's new powers
are put to good use again when she comes
face to face
with marvel's biggest douchebag
[Music]
nice tricks i like yours too this guy
really tried to gun down two little kids
next week we're gonna see a deleted
scene we've traveled all the way to
sokovia
to take a dump on wanda's bomb that old
family apartment is hayward
actually the most evil character in the
mcu
in the end it isn't hayward or sword or
even agatha that puts an end to wanda's
sitcom dream life
it's wanda herself in order to save the
innocent people she's trapped who are
suffering not just because of her grief
but are suffering with it she has to
sacrifice the dream she built
the hex comes down she puts her boys to
sleep in their beds
for the last time and says goodbye once
again
to her true love what am i
you vision
are the piece of the mind stone that
lives in me
the real world isn't a very sunny place
for wanda as the residents she trapped
clearly
fear and hate her something might i add
that mutants
are very used to so no i didn't get my
big magneto reveal but we do get some
clear parallels here
between wanda and dear old dad who she
has never met
and might never meet we also get some
parallels to doctor strange
as she studies the dark hold in that end
credit scene
he also never shows up
okay in that vein here's a quick rundown
of theories
that went nowhere in a very ben kingsley
mandarin twist fake pietro is not
quicksilver there was no reveal of
mephisto doctor strange's
mia there was no reed richards to storm
blue marvel wonder man or grim reaper
and even paul bettany himself led us
astray with this little number
there are scenes that i can't talk about
episodes that i can't talk about in the
latter half of the
show that where for instance i get to
work with one of
an actor that i really admire and that
i've always wanted to work with
whose work i just really trust
implicitly and
and we have this you know these
explosive
scenes now as someone who loves to
theorize about these things i could see
how someone might be disappointed with
the way the series is ending
you can see the various trails of
breadcrumbs that lead nowhere but like
i've said
before half the fun of watching these
superhero shows and movies
is guessing what comes next and being
surprised when the result
isn't exactly what you expected whether
you personally thought it was the right
call
or not from the beginning one thing
about wandavision has remained true
guess which clip we're gonna roll we
just don't know what to expect
that's the one and what we did get is
something that i think many of us were
not expecting
an honest profile on grief the things we
do to survive it and the love and
sacrifice it takes
to move on all this wrapped up in a
super meta hero story featuring a mind
controlling witch
a machine man husband and some magical
wiggly boots
really so what did you think was one
division everything you hoped it would
be or were you underwhelmed
are you looking forward to more skrulls
in the mcu
and do we think that billy and tommy are
alive
and are just trapped in the multiverse
of
madness m o m
mom she's totally going after them isn't
she she is
well let's talk about it in the comments
below if you like this video
a thumbs up would be very helpful feel
free to share this maybe with
your mom and confuse the hell out of her
if she hasn't been watching the show
and has no idea what we're talking about
that's it for me
you can follow me on instagram at
mostbot we're counting down the days
until the falcon and the winter soldier
comes out but until then we've got a lot
more nerdy and
not so nerdy videos for you see you next
time